welcome to this video our seniors with
black soul a forearm yeah should I play
b6 again the Owens defense let's try
what what do they have in store them we
should be three there's f5 unfortunately
not playable this is a more conventional
okay so we should III okay maybe I get
that this is not that bad it still might
be a decent French defense later so
Knight f6 if I Bishop g2 right no
slopped going for that so that's also
not not exactly very threatening against
b6 okay it's not bad for white but not
exactly a refutation either so what am i
doing Bishop a six maybe let's let's get
rid of that bloody bishop this place is
my okay didn't do it didn't take would
have misplaced my night
okay let's put it back f-for g6g for
that might be possible I'm Sam I'm
absolutely not developed yeah ug form
might be on I have new development yeah
h 5 f-5 and i'm probably busted okay i
have to be covered here maybe i can get
in Long castles f5 Bishop g5 was my idea
maybe fact if I can take Queen edge for
long castles this could be playable yeah
it looked a lot like a French and my i
cannot i simply cannot play the French
it's an opening that I cannot blame
okay so yeah take first
yeah 90 f 4 it's also Muslim next gym if
I take it my dark squares are horrible
but I really i have to have to cancel i
cannot i cannot avoid that i have to
cancel maybe maybe it's not so bad i can
trade trade heavy pieces on a very good
day i might claim that this Bishop is
not so great okay night is 7i guess
I guess 97 but I can Cass along next
ride I didn't see reason not to check
just to just not sure him may be here
now that knee goes to have some and it's
just not good push-up g3 m4h form I'm
feeling like rook e8 h for Queen g5 I
know I can actually go to h5 so it's not
that terrible let's do that I was
thinking h4 Queen h6 g5 Queen g7 rook f6
but I can put the Queen on h 5 which is
really helping a bit okay i have a check
here there should be three
okay if a jig and rook a fade
now note 9 i'd be 596 mm-hmm but I have
a counter-attack yeah I really have a
counter-attack so that that moves it
seems to be okay hope I'm not blundering
stuff I have Quincy one that's a very
important move not just queen III might
be 596 is playable group d 7 Quincy one
Quincy 1 Kings you took will have one
made yeah some 96 and looked at seven
Quincy one check in G took winner one
made and if he has to trade now I'm in
really good shape because well gee for
c1 and all hangs and his queen is
offside I'm not getting made attentively
yeah and now it now I'm in great shape
whether it's a storm here so probably
here and the check check check on see to
check back here everything is protected
I hope
Joe it's amazingly save the Knights
defend everything and I have aged five
next getting to his skin that seemed
very dangerous from that he probably had
had options there to punish yes I can
just take it I really can mmm but not
just just one moment damned if I go age
54 the counter attack aged 5 and he's
not really threatening obviously not
really threatening anything let's do
that Queen a six then I can take it so
check its it's not a check he's covering
that what a silly idea I was close to
playing Queen er5 check totally
forgetting about the noid you haven't no
idea know what I'm buy my ticket he
doesn't have a check so Queen a five for
the end game long
check let's do that the king is fob but
can I believe it i have the f porn so
what now night on f8 we've always stop
it it's no not that one no no my
opponent can run white resigns oh that
was shaky as usual when I get some kind
of French position and that didn't look
too great for white somehow but this is
probably wrong yeah I tend to I know
that one one one of my problems with
playing the friends that I tend to I
don't attack the tent don't attack the
center with enough force I really know
that problem but it's so difficult for
me to fix that I don't have French
positions that much anyway with good
reason yeah computer is giving why the
huge advantage not very surprising me
with what exactly not here this is a
good movie is a good move he threatening
Bishop g5 nuts 97 and they're just I
have to play rook c8 which means no
canceling and now this and this is
complete rubbish if I cannot get the
King out of it hmm now that it cannot be
a good position for black
amazingly this is just 0.6 so it doesn't
seem to be that terrible and here
equally of check Jim following basically
the comp comes mainline computer still
gives each form I thought this line I
saw this idea this is very nice for wide
yeah this is the sacrifice I mean it's
not a sacrifice I cannot take on f6 but
I thought queen age 5 might be good
enough trying to yeah BB be near the
King yeah in the in the right moment
probably equal ish no computers he is
unequal but here oh he actually has a
good way here I thought I'm in good
shape but I overlooked something very
nice idea okay i will look chance what
did he play actually not be fine after
that I'm winning after that I'm winning
Quincy one quince to ya okay I'm winning
but he could have shaken and play Queen
everyone those moves are very difficult
to see for a human especially with
limited time the long Queen retreats
very difficult moves yeah the night is
attacked and if I move it he's coming in
and does in good shape why this much
much better him that's very difficult to
see Queen f1 what I'm wondering is here
I did Jack consider that check
of course of course I can just take the
bloody rook yeah yeah check I have that
move nothing happens yeah because now
here is no Queen c7 made i have taken
see tubers check so that was much much
better and he can draw check 96 wow
that's nice very nice move yeah I've at
ignou route 27 now here's the counter
maid and I'm forced to check 21 22 to go
for a draw this channel made you can
take it they are here to give the way
you give away the night for two reasons
covering that and opening up the
seventh-ranked so white has to go hang
up and ash a check and we will check
that Jonas for Jack okay honey would
have been a cute draw check okay and
after the trade I am really bad i am
check I am check yeah tricky tricky game
shaky game yeah again this is the b6
line this is dangerous normally own
bikini six think actually that this is a
pretty good line Bishop g4 92 it's
pretty good for white as one of the best
lines if gives white a very convenient
advantage okay well thanks for watching